I saw photos of you and your good friend
mr. Jason Bateman hanging out together
paparazzi photos and these are real and
I think you should probably explain what
happened here describe what happened
clearly here
yeah we're walking down the street in
New York and so we just thought and then
you know in the New York sometimes the
the paparazzi guys they ride around on
bikes and yeah they run they ride ahead
and then they get to the end of the
block and they start snapping pics and
they want to get you like you know
picking your nose or whatever and I said
the Bateman I said you know let's let's
have fun at their expense and just
grabbed his hand which he was way too
cool with you think he was like he
seemed to be going really like sweaty
palms I'll just say that and and I feel
like his internal monologue was finally
I could tell that you're acting but he's
totally in it's really we try I wanted
to make it look like we were just to you
know just two guys out just doing a
little afternoon shopping in the village
which is actually what we were doing
who's the joke I'm by the way you can
tell by the photo on on the top there V
V that short for obvious I don't know
it's a now you're in the new teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles movie yeah this is
uh this is summer yeah it's huge it's uh
first of all they're teenagers
so let's it's uh it was a really fun
really fun movie produced by Michael Bay
and with the Turtles and me and Megan
Fox who yeah she's not difficult to look
at and so we got to we shot that in New
York that summer it's a really fun big
family film filled with explosions and
car chases and stuff well you you're not
a turtle then no I'm not I'm currently
not a turtle
no no but well you know you what do you
play I'm a live-action guy I play a guy
who's kind of who ends up reluctantly
helping Megan Fox help the turtles in
their quest against the evildoers yeah
yeah that sounds cool yeah it's really
fun I'll take my kids to see it yeah
great
how are your kids by the way what are
they are they do they know what you do
right they know that dad's a famous guy
as a TV show yeah I mean I think that
that aspect of it it is is kind of lost
I mean I do it they do know the other
day absolutely true the other day my son
was playing about five feet from me with
his cars and I heard him say that's
professional grade
thank your catcher yeah my son hurts he
and I kind of and I kind of said wait
what did you say I'm thinking like this
little pug you know oh you think he's
trying to he's know my lawn like he's
just he's just sharpening his knife just
waiting for me pops to knock off a
little kids very strange